good morning ukraine's president has
warned russia to expect a day of
judgment instead of forgiveness
delivering his nightly address to the
ukrainian people he said that hundreds
of missiles had hit ukraine creating
suffering for thousands the casualties
included a mum and her two young
children killed in mortar fire as they
tried to flee from urban near kiev as
the shelling of civilians areas
intensifies people are desperate to
escape as you can imagine
taking you through the latest
developments according to the ministry
of defense russian grand forces have
made minimal advances over the weekend
and it's highly unlikely that they'll
have achieved their planned objectives
over the last 24 hours russia has
conducted more air and artillery strikes
on military and civilian targets
in ukrainian cities russia's defense
ministry says humanitarian corridors
will be opened this morning to allow
civilians to escape from kiev mariopol
kharkiv and sumi more than 10 000 people
have applied for the uk's family visa
scheme since sunday here in the uk
around 50 have been granted visas so far
sally lockwood has our first report
a new week brings no fresh start no end
to this suffering just another challenge
of survival
kharkiv faced more bombardment overnight
russian forces stepped up heavy shelling
in cities across the country
president zielenski has expressed anger
at what he called silence from western
leaders as russia said its strikes would
continue
we will not forgive the shooting of
unarmed people the destruction of our
infrastructure we will not forgive
hundreds and hundreds of victims
thousands and thousands of sufferings
instead of forgiveness there will be a
day of judgment
tough words and harsh sanctions have
done nothing to deter vladimir putin
in a phone call with his turkish
counterpart the russian president said
the fighting would continue until
moscow's demands are met
and so the inhumanity continues to
efforts to evacuate two hundred thousand
people from the port city of mariopol
have failed for a second day
most people here sleeping underground
after a week of almost constant shelling
one and a half million people have now
fled the country in just 12 days
brave souls fleeing for their lives like
this eleven-year-old who traveled by
train to slovakia on his own
arriving with a small bag and a
telephone number written on his hand
his mother has thanked slovakian
authorities
there's a nuclear power plant next to my
town which the russians are shooting at
it was on fire i can't leave my mother
she can't move independently so i sent
my son alone on a train towards the
slovak border
there he met people with a big heart
your small country has people with big
hearts please save our ukrainian
children and give them a safe haven
the world is watching this war unfold in
horror
with a third round of talks between
russia and ukraine expected later
the need for a breakthrough grows ever
urgent
sally lockwood sky news
i'll speak to the minister in just a
moment but first let's bring in uh
alastair he's in cirret on the romanian
border with ukraine it's just
heartbreaking alastair what have you
been seeing over the last few hours
oh yeah i mean the images are utterly
heartbreaking um to watch some day in
day out particularly of mothers and
children obviously the husband's left
behind uh so it is women and children
the vast majority who are fleeing
ukraine and they are doing so incredibly
difficult and challenging
circumstances this ceasefire has just
come into force we will see how long it
lasts a couple of issues firstly some of
the humanitarian corridors we understand
are into russian territory so what
people really want to flee basically
into the arms of their attackers
secondly after two attempts over the
weekend uh both didn't work will russia
keep its promise this time and allow the
ceasefire and the evacuation of
civilians to go ahead and thirdly there
is a fear that the russians might be
using these ceasefires
as a way of suggesting that they are uh
you know having a humanitarian agenda uh
when in fact what we're seeing on the
ground is far from it and they might
also use the ceasefires to restock
regroup resupply after what has been a
reasonably stuttering advance in recent
days
okay alastair thank you
okay
um we will be talking in more detail
about that throughout the course of the
morning as you can imagine but first
let's bring in the europe minister james
cleverly mr cleverley thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
humanitarian corridors uh refugees being
bombed as they try to flee how can we
help
well we
we see these images and of course
everybody wants to help in whatever way
they can and we've seen this huge
generosity of the british people in
collecting
uh things like nappies and and food and
medical supplies which are being shipped
out to poland and the ukrainian border
the government announced of course our
own humanitarian aid package 100 million
in economic support over uh
120 million in direct humanitarian
support and we have of course also
announced the fact that we will be
opening uh two schemes by which
ukrainians can come to the uk the family
reconciliation scheme
and also a broader humanitarian scheme
because we want to come to that we want
to also we will come to ukrainians in
that way as well yeah under what
circumstances would we consider given
that we've seen babies in arms being
murdered and their mothers as well as
they try to flee under what
circumstances would we consider a no-fly
zone so the russians can't do that
well this has been discussed at length
and both the secretary general of nato
the prime minister and others have said
that we've got to understand what a
no-fly zone means it would mean that not
only would there be uh russian uh
aircraft prevented from fly but also
ukrainian aircraft from prevented from
flying and in order to bring a no-fly
zone
in it would need to be enforced and that
would almost inevitably mean that we
would be engaged directly
with russian aircraft and
dragged into this conflict directly
which we've said is not appropriate for
for nato
but we are
continuing to provide defensive military
equipment support to the ukrainian armed
forces
we've seen that be incredibly effective
um those uh end laws those those
anti-tank missiles that we've provided
and the training that we've given over
the years have proven to be really
really effective but
the the secretary general of nato and
others have made it clear that we we
must not uh be engaged directly in this
conflict okay if um refugees do manage
to get as far as calais why aren't we
making it easier for them to get into
the uk
well we
we are uh we have made it absolutely
clear that we will be uh supportive of
refugees at the moment of course
the vast vast majority of refugees are
in the country's
neighboring um
ukraine and we are providing
humanitarian support
to those refugees via those host nation
countries because that's where that's
where the problem is at the moment most
of these people of course want to get
back to their own homes
as quickly as possible we have made it
clear that of course we will be generous
and open-hearted as you would expect to
ukrainians uh speaking to come here to
the uk
okay let me play this to you then given
what you've just said
the french people let me through they
let me through but then you come to the
uk border in calais
uh and and they said i'm sorry you can't
get on a ferry uh we'll escort you back
up to the office
so we're not making it easy at all are
we
well i don't know the details of that
particular circumstance but the um
the the uk we have made it absolutely
clear we want to support uh ukrainians
who are seeking refuge uh both those who
have family connections here in the uk
uh and indeed those who don't um and you
know over the last 10 days or so we have
seen huge numbers of people
leaving ukraine fleeing from the
conflict we will as i say support them
in the places where they currently are
which is typically
in the countries
bordering ukraine but we will of course
also welcome ukrainians uh here to to
the uk
um let's see
a thousand people we've only got a
limited amount of time mr cleveland
thirteen and a half thousand people have
applied to uh
come to the uk visa applications so far
one can only imagine how difficult it is
to do that in a war zone they have we've
allowed 50 to be granted that's not
acceptable
well you've got to remember that this
situation has occurred only over the
last couple of days one and a half
million people have gone into ireland
this situation has only occurred in the
last couple of days of course the vast
majority of people have just crossed the
border into
the neighboring countries and of course
what we are saying is we are supporting
them there we have allocated hundreds of
millions of pounds worth of humanitarian
and economic support we are also going
to make sure that we host ukrainians
here in the uk whether uh temporarily
until we want to go back to the uk um
we've got to we've got to make we've got
to make sure we've got to make sure
that we um we have uh the uh you know
processes in place to do that in those
processes these people literally are
fleeing for their life if you're going
to ask questions you've got to let me
answer and you keep saying it
we only have a limited amount of time
and you're going off at a tangent i'm
bringing you back
this is what my viewers want to know
this morning minister if i may
13 and a half thousand people have asked
to come to the uk 50 have been told that
they can we just heard from a brit there
who's brought his family he's in calais
he can't get across the water he was
welcomed all the way he wants to come
home and we won't let him
well as i say i don't have details of
that if you pass me the details of that
individual case i'll make sure that we
that we look at that but we have
processes in place whereby people with
family here in the uk and indeed those
without family in the uk can come to the
uk you say so far only small numbers
have come thus far and i would remind
you that the process has only just
started and the vast majority of people
are physically still in the country's
neighboring uk so neighboring ukraine
that is where we are providing the
support initially because that's where
the problem currently is we want to help
these people whether they be
in uh in bulgaria slovakia poland where
a large number of people are but also we
want to help them when they come to the
uk and we have okay two routes family
reconciliation route and a route for
people that don't have family both those
agreements
50 people out of 13 and a half thousand
have been allowed in so far that those
are well that number let me talk to you
if i
we've gone around the houses on that one
the conversation between the two leaders
both our leader and uh the leader of
ukraine um we have agreed that we'll
send further defensive equipment what
does that actually involve will it
include fighter jets
no we've we've already said we're not
going to engage in a no-fly zone we have
seen the equipment that has been
incredibly effective uh those um end
laws those anti-tank missile systems
and other equipment which would probably
best not uh discussed uh on the on the
television but the point is that we have
continued to do what we have done over
years which is support ukrainians in
their defense um the the feedback that
we have from them about that has been
uh has been really heartening they value
that equipment that we have uh supplied
them it's made a it's made a real
difference and we'll continue as part of
the prime minister's six-point plan we
will continue to help the ukrainians
defend themselves against this illegal
completely unjustified attack the
economic crime bill in parliament uh
today labour's tabled an amendment to
shorten the enforcement to 28 days i
believe presently it's looking like
something like six months is that
something that the government will
consider
well obviously we are working across
party to make sure this is as effective
as possible i have to say in my
conversations with the labour front
bench
they have been incredibly pragmatic in
their desire to make sure this is
effective as possible obviously we'll
see what happens with regard to the
amendments i'm sure there'll be others
tabled as well but the ultimate goal
is to make sure that the sanctions that
we've already put in place which are
incredibly effective and have had a real
impact on russian oligarchs and indeed
the russian uh economy
are made even stronger still and we
welcome cross-party support in that the
prime minister said a hundred 275
individuals have been sanctioned a
hundred individuals last week alone uh
looking at a fact checker uh our figures
are suggesting that is 15. which of
those figures is correct well your
figures are wrong okay why is the prime
minister's figures um correct 100
individuals are you sure
well we have we've uh we have targeted
sorry that's what he said in parliament
didn't he
well as i say the the the figures you
put forward i don't recognize those
figures at all we've had a very wide
ranging number um uh over 200
individuals and entities over uh 250
billion
pounds worth of uh
russian economic activity curtailed
over three million russian companies now
longer able to raise finance on the
london market so the fact that vladimir
putin singled us out for criticism is a
badge of honor and i think that we will
see that strengthen even further still
okay unfortunately i do have to go i
told your studio that i have to be clear
for another interview i have at 7 20. so
i'm afraid i'm gonna have to go now i'm
sure thank you
thank you
okay make of that what you will um the
war in ukraine continues to dominate the
front pages the times leads with the
headline families flee for their lives
as the agreed humanitarian corridor was
shelled by russia yesterday the daily
mirror has a picture of a man escaping
bombing with the child with the words
save them as far as rage in the
background it also urges the government
here to do more to help refugees come to
this country daily telegraph leads on
the prime minister condemning vladimir
putin's actions as barbaric after
civilians attempting to flee the
invasion of ukraine were killed by
russian
shells plea for safe passage reports the
the guardian rather has the second
attempt to hold a ceasefire fails daily
mail quotes the uk's top military
commander admiral tony radekin who said
vladimir putin could still lose the war
in ukraine after suffering losses to his
forces
i'm just processing those figures that
we um gave to the minister
yep the prime minister did say 100
individuals he told parliament 100
individuals last week
had been sanctioned 100 um
russian individuals um our figures are
suggesting 15 he says they're wrong
we'll um check those out further because
we're not wrong and we'll see what
happens next uh coming up on the
programme joined by lord danette former
head of the british army and patron of
the charity hope for homes about the
impact of war on orphans
we'll speak to the mayor of mikala for
russian forces
as i should forgive me as russian forces
push to take the key black seaport city
and we meet a brit who's come out of
retirement to join the ukrainian war
effort we'll also be looking in more
detail at the suggestions uh by the
government that they're doing absolutely
everything that they can to help
refugees come to the uk if they wanted
to the latest figures i was just sharing
with you on that thirteen and a half
thousand have started a visa application
50
have been granted but we are doing
everything we can just a reminder that
uh poland have taken a million refugees
so far people going to the borders
holding up signs saying we've got room
come and stay
with us a brit trapped at the border in
calais with his family of four couldn't
get across the border united nations
says russia's invasion of ukraine has
created the fastest growing refugee
crisis since the second world war more
than one and a half million people have
fled to neighbouring countries so far uh
including romania uh ali is there for us
this morning the minister was having
none of it um this morning um ali what
are the countries bordering ukraine
doing amidst the snow there
a lot i mean they are doing a lot uh
when the refugees come over the border
they are welcomed immediately
by normally members of the fire brigade
or policemen who help them carry their
luggage they wheel their
bags they they take heavy bags they put
them in their shoulders they pick up
some of the younger children
and they then take them sort of through
various stages of giving them hot food
making sure they're okay making sure
they're medically okay
and then dispersing them either where
they want to go because some people do
arrive with a plan they might have
relatives elsewhere in europe that they
want to get to so they'll be helped to
train stations or to airports for
example or if they don't have a plan and
i think probably most don't because they
were never intending to
flee their country in this way
then um they are looked after either in
private houses around the area we were
in a hotel yesterday in a wedding hall
that has just been converted into sort
of a vast sea of mattresses where people
can come they can have some sleep uh
some of the local teachers are there to
entertain the children and look after
them as well and take their minds off
of what they've seen and
you know they cannot be doing more for
the refugees that are coming over the
border a word to
to a lot of people in britain i mean
certainly from our reports a lot of
people have been in contact asking what
they can do can they pay for flights can
they give people jobs can they give
people a place to stay so you do get
this sense very very quickly of
solidarity across across europe there
are millions of people coming in and the
stream is just continuing it i can only
think that it will go on and get more
and more as the war and the conflict uh
spreads throughout ukraine but there is
no suggestion here that the um the
generosity the kindness that people are
showing is going to abate in any way
they know that more and more people are
going to come and they're just going to
do whatever they need to do in order to
look after them and make sure
everybody's fine
um yeah and what sort of aid are they
getting from the rest of europe those uh
to be able to help people as they cross
the border
so there are trucks arriving with food
there are trucks arriving with
clothes that have been donated uh it
seems yesterday when we were on the
border that a a lot of
quite thin duvets but duvets nonetheless
were being given to people when they
came because it is bitterly cold here
so anything that you can think of that
might just help them in their first kind
of couple of hours when they arrive from
ukraine uh is coming here there's a lot
of international aid charities as well
that are starting to set themselves up
here because you've got a lot of um
people from all over the world who are
coming out of ukraine okay the majority
are ukrainians but there are an awful
lot of international uh students and
workers for example that are coming out
as well they need to be looked after and
uh their their journeys home need to be
sorted out and so you see
the global aid efforts sort of centering
on romania slovakia hungary moldova
poland
and it is needed
okay thank you thanks a lot just a
reminder on those figures uh more than a
million people have gone into poland one
and a half million refugees uh 13 and a
half thousand people have applied for a
visa application to the uk so far 50
have been granted more than 200 children
evacuated from orphanages in areas being
attacked by russian troops have arrived
in the western city of lev
the children ranging from toddlers to
teenagers left their orphanage
in the south east of ukraine on the day
russian troops took control of the
nearby nuclear power station
quick look at the weather for you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
the start of the week promises largely
fine condition thanks to high pressure
drifting across the north but as it
clears it'll allow atlantic cloud and
rain to move in from the west
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
just want to share these images with you
it'll melt your heart this morning
two army reservists have got marriage at
a checkpoint near kiev wearing their
military uniforms lesia and valerie tied
the knot in front of fellow soldiers and
a military chaplain
how lovely is that now what about if
that didn't do it for you what about
this one
[Music]
apparently that's a rendition of frozen
in ukrainian this little girl kept
ukrainian spirits up even when holed up
in a bomb shelter with her rendition of
um let it go in the past hour i asked
the europe minister james cleverly why
so few visas had been processed and i
use the example of a british man trying
to return home who's stuck in france
with his ukrainian family because uk
authorities
won't let them in
we've got to make sure
that we um we have uh the uh you know
processes in place to do that and those
processes these people literally are
fleeing for their life if you're going
to ask questions you've got to let me
answer you keep saying you're sure i'm
so sad we only have a limited amount of
time and you're going off at a tangent
i'm bringing you back
this is what my viewers want to know
this morning minister if i may
13 and a half thousand people have asked
to come to the uk 50 have been told that
they can we just heard from a brit there
who's brought his family he's in calais
he can't get across the water he was
welcomed all the way he wants to come
home and we won't let him
well as i say i don't have details of
that if you pass me the details of that
individual case i'll make sure that we
that we look at that but we have
processes in place whereby people with
family here in the uk and indeed those
without family in the uk can come to the
uk
only small numbers have come thus far
and i would remind you that the process
has only just
started
tamara's here oh my goodness it was a
testy exchange this morning indeed you
feel that the government are um very
defensive about this whole issue of
immigration and visas the home office
revealed yesterday that only around 50
have been granted out of about five and
a half thousand and people from ukraine
who have completed submitted their
biometric data their applications are
ready to go and this is under the family
schemes of people who have a family
member in the uk who want to join those
who want to come and yes that's only one
percent of those and then you've got
people who don't have any links to the
uk who may be able to come through a new
humanitarian route where they get
sponsored by an organization or a local
council for example but that's we don't
really have any details of that scheme
yet um pretty patel the home secretary
has mentioned it in an interview with
the newspaper today but we don't really
have any details of it yet so you've got
these hundreds of thousands of desperate
people pouring across the borders as she
herself has seen when she went to poland
this week and clamor from labour and
tory mps to say are these people having
to jump through too many hoops to come
to britain now the government say look
the scheme has only been really up and
running since friday so we they're
getting through them as quickly as
possible and sources in government i
spoke today said look we are aware that
there is a backlog and we're going to
try and get through the completed
applications as quickly as we can i was
also told that that initial estimate
that the people coming through all these
routes would number about 200 000 is
going to go up a lot and james cleverley
seemed to concede that in his interview
with you as well uh he did and as far as
the economic crime bill that's coming
through later on today labour want that
to be reduced uh significantly so that
people don't have time to hide their
money i'm guessing that's right so this
is legislation that's been promised
since david cameron back in 2016 and
it's now finally happening it's been
fast-tracked all stages through
parliament today so this probably
wouldn't have happened without the
current crisis and it will mean that as
boris johnson put it the owners of these
huge houses in london bought through
offshore companies the owners will be
unmasked now the governments say there
has to be six months implementation
period to get this to work labor say it
should be 28 days because otherwise
people might just rather than comply
just sell their homes and take their
money elsewhere
now the governments say that they see
that and they've already reduced it from
18 months to six but you've got to be
realistic about how long the processes
take i mean the process of selling a
house in general can often take longer
than six months so they say they're
speeding through it as quickly as
possible i think they'll be wanting to
take a sense of how many tory mps might
vote for labour's proposal before they
give any ground on that one and the pm
finally just to clarify saying 100
entities have been sanctioned um last
week um the fact checks that i've been
looking at are suggesting it's nearer to
15 which one's right so this is the
prime minister meant to say a hundred
individuals and entities because um it
is it is the government had announced
they were going to sanction a hundred
companies and people but the number of
actual individual oligarchs is still
quite small as you say because um the
government say that while they've got a
hit list which we haven't seen they need
to make sure that each individual case
is watertight because if anyone
challenged it in the courts and won that
would be a bit of a propaganda coup for
the russian side so they want to make
sure before they take a super-rich
billionaire with lots of properties in
the uk
to court to try and impose sanctions
they want to make sure they're all ready
to go and they say that some of the
legislation on that which is going
through today should be ready next week
so we may hear more then but it is not a
hundred individuals and there's been
criticism of the fact that some
individuals who have property in the uk
linked to vladimir putin have been
sanctioned by the eu and by the us but
not by us okay see i'm not going mad
thank you i'll see you um at nine
o'clock tomorrow's take look forward to
it thank you
nice guy news has spoken to families
fleeing their homes in the town of open
just outside kiev which has endured
sustained shelling some claimed russian
forces are targeting schools and
hospitals there and that children have
been killed in the conflict
from open our special correspondent alex
crawford reports
they were running for their lives
frantically trying to keep their
families together amid the mayhem and
gunfire desperately handing over their
toddlers to soldiers and strangers
scrambling to get away from the firing
and shelling even as they fled
many have spent days under fire trapped
in their homes until they realized it
was run or die with the russians getting
closer
in my city
and
the killing people
urpin on the outskirts of the capital is
being relentlessly shelled
and there's no escape not even for the
civilians you can see at the top of your
picture running with their cases to get
away
this is an entirely residential area
two children and their mother were
killed outright
but this area is filled with families
utterly powerless against this attacking
army
the bombed bridge connecting open with
kiev is now a target for the russian
troops
and those trying to escape came under
fire several times
the ukrainian soldiers tried to shoot
down drones pinpointing the positions of
the fleeing families
those rushing to get out are the most
vulnerable who felt too nervous to try
to escape until now when there was no
other option
but this route used by hundreds 24 hours
earlier is now desperately
dangerous and the attackers are showing
no mercy
the stream of people fleeing are
traumatized but many are also angry and
full of despair
putin's a war criminal she says the
antichrist you've been waiting for him
now you've got him
there is incredible heartache in fear
but also an astonishing defiance about
these people
alex crawford sky news in open
ukrainian government has said the
southern city of microlife is one of the
areas to come under heavy shelling in
the latest wave of missile strikes the
city's mayor is alexander sankovic and
he is joining us now hello to you thank
you so much for taking the time to join
us this morning what's happened
overnight where you are
hello studio uh today it's
5 00 am we were bombed
by russian
troops
almost all bombs felt
on the
city civilian
buildings i mean
houses of the people
and uh
we had a lot of bombs fallen and
unexploded almost 40 bomb
fell down and had not unexploded all the
bombs were this cluster bomb cassette
bombs or how they call it uh it's the
big bomb which uh divides on small bombs
and then explodes and kill
civilian and people so it's not about
fight with uh
military uh troops but more with
civilian and uh today we are fighting
with fire on those buildings uh starting
from the morning and uh we still have no
confirmation about dead people because
we were prepared for for this bombing
and people were in um
in special places
but uh about 60 people endured
so uh
yes this morning was like you know uh
wake up call was with the bombs
i i wonder if i could just check with
you there mr mayor because
i was under the um maybe misapprehension
that cluster bombs have been banned so
are you saying that cluster bombs are
being dropped on your city this morning
sure right we have the confirmation we
have those bombs uh in
in my facebook i made a photo of this
type of bombs the small bomb what left
from it and uh yeah they they uh
for sure they use these cluster bombs
so these bombs that are banned under
international law are being dropped on
your city by uh by russian uh military
this morning
sure they they uh
there is no uh
another way that we saw that with that
bombs we have confirmation uh more of a
lot of uh different journalists from uh
different countries made photos of these
bombs moreover they bombed also our zoo
so
nothing no military object there on in
our zoo so now our zoo is the best zoo
in ukraine where the best zoo in ukraine
and we have
now problems there and people uh
we
we do
a special corridors and people go out of
the city right now moving to odessa this
is the only way for us to
escape
to evacuate people because
they gather with the troops around the
city from kirsan to
krapovninsky so almost let's say
three quarters of circle is closed by
their troops
um are they honoring that humanitarian
corridor mr mayor
uh no uh
so we don't have any corridors right now
because we have a
free road to odessa so
we haven't created any corridors until
we have this way to escape the sea but
they hear some the city near us
for about 50 kilometers from us they are
closed and they don't have a green
corridor uh russian troops don't give
them a corridor we even can give them uh
the medicine the food
and they are really close so they
propose them
their help russian help russian medicine
russian food but people from the city
prefer not to take it and they made a
meeting there yesterday with the
ukrainian flags and saying that they
don't expect for russia to save them but
they are part of ukraine
mr um can the ukrainian people
understand
why
nato countries can't get involved with a
no-fly zone
uh you know uh that the southern ukraine
uh is russian speaking moreover i would
say that in my daily life usual life i
use russian language as uh as native i i
i think
uh using russian
so uh a lot of people were you know kind
of in love with russia because they
loved soviet union a lot of things good
things made in our city were made while
uh
soviet union existence but uh
i think
no one i mean
uh
no
people
who say that you we have here in ukraine
narcissist ukrainian nationalist they
never made more than putin made for
ukraine to understand that russians are
invaders that are
our enemies because they bomb our
russian-speaking language uh
people and
i think people uh
woke up
uh after so many years of uh
independence in ukraine
just before i let you go mr mayor did
you ever
expect in your lifetime to be in a
position
where russia invaded your country
to be honest
i became mayor in 2016 2016 and
before that i was i.t interpreter so i
was a programmer and uh
and i had a company
and i think everyone in the world
understand that there is nothing
good in war and we
never expected the war to come to our
country
but now we are in this situation we are
in conditions of war a lot of people are
really
uh
you know
frustrated they don't know what what to
do
where to run and right now i'm talking
to you and i hear the bombs
uh
in our city so uh
no no one expected
we heard the information from uh uh
special services of the united states
and uk that put in plans to invade
ukraine to
to go with to us with war but we
never believed in that right now we have
more
you know
we have all the evidences of this war so
and you see
the world seeing and we expect the help
as for nikolai we
we need really neat helmets and we need
uh west for our territorial defense uh
troops and uh
we're also gathering the
food
for long-term um that can be long-term
story
i understand um
you're so brave and the people of
ukraine are being so brave and um be
safe in the knowledge that the british
people wish that they could do more and
are
raising as much money as they possibly
can to try to help your people
hopefully this bloody war will not
continue for too much longer thank you
so much for taking the time to join us
this morning thank you thank you thank
you
uh let's bring in uh general lord
richard danny former chief of the
general staff i'm talking to us about uh
children's charities but if i wonder if
i could start please uh lord danette
good morning to you uh dropping cluster
bombs on residential areas surely that's
against any international law that you
can think of
it's certainly against any international
decency that you can think of now there
is an international treaty that bans
cluster weapons but the sad news here is
that russia has not signed that
international treaty so vladimir putin
and his generals don't feel bound by the
ban on cluster weapons that's part of
the tragedy
what's your assessment of the situation
on the ground at the moment there
well what we can continue to see is the
stalling of the military maneuvers if
you like that were designed ultimately
to knock out the capital kiev um yes
they are achieving some success in the
south in trying to isolate ukraine from
the freshwater port but what we're
seeing and this is the absolute tragedy
is that towns are being surrounded and
the
really appalling
scheme of maneuver is being put in place
whereby the city centers are being
shelled and civilians are being killed
in large numbers
and as you know kay one of the reasons
why i wanted to talk this morning is
amongst the biggest sufferers here are
children and particularly children who
are not with their own families this war
has exposed
a fragility in ukrainian society
which has continued to focus on children
being in orphanages believe it or not
there are over 700 orphanages in ukraine
that's actually more orphanages and
we've got hospitals uh in the united
kingdom and a hundred thousand children
more than a hundred thousand children
are in those orphanages and of course
they're at huge risk at the present time
and
it has relied on on charities to to help
in particular open homes for children
which was a charity bred by colonel mark
cook in the terrible days of the bosnian
war 30 years ago and hope and homes for
children have had a real heart for these
children as they are being extracted
from places of danger to places of
safety and i really hope that amongst
many of the
pressures that are tugging on on sky
news viewers hearts at the present
moment
some thought particular thought can be
given to children in danger
and possibly some donations found to
find their way to hope and homes for
children who've got teams out there
trying to look after these children and
protect them it's it's one of the
unsung parts of the tragedy of all this
that this awful
this awful technique that the russians
are using of shelling civilians it's
children not with their families who are
suffering hugely and these little ones
are in orphanages not with their
families as you say and the people i'm
guessing that were looking after them
torn because they have to decide whether
to stay to look after those children or
to flee with their own children
well that's part of the tragedy i mean
there are some fantastic workers i know
and have seen reports that are staying
with the children in their care but when
they've got their own children their own
families and the terror is rising to
huge heights those staff can't be blamed
for wanting to prioritize their own
families and then that leaves the
children in care in institutions in
orphanages really to fend for themselves
and one just hopes that
one positive that might come out of this
is a change in ukrainian society if you
remember when chi question was
deposed
in romania there was the most awful
scandal exposed of the number of
orphanages in in romania well that has
changed their policy has changed there
are very few orphanages in romania now
but actually ukraine hasn't gone down
that track there are still as i say over
700 orphanages in in ukraine well hopes
that might change over time and that
this war will expose the danger of
putting children
into orphanages institutions like that
much better to try and get them into
foster families and to families who will
love them and care for them and look
after them and then when something awful
like this happens those children will be
removed with their own children to
places of safety so you know top marks
to mark cook and open homes for children
they've been battering away in war zones
for the last 30 years and this has
really brought the importance of their
work home and i just hope that skyny's
viewers will find it in their hearts put
their hand in their pocket go online to
open homes and donate towards this
really really important work
and the website is hope and homes
for children
yeah just go just just put in hope and
homes and you and you'll find it it's a
very good website it's very clear and um
i just hope lots of viewers will do that
because
well children
are one of the casualties of war perhaps
the most pathetic casualties of war and
hope and homes are doing their level
best to try and help as many children as
they can both as they flee ukraine and
over into moldova moldova and in romania
so the top marks to that team frankly
my lord i know as a former military man
you tiptoe through the raindrops when it
comes to um politics um but i wondered
if you had a thought on the number of
visas that have been issued for um those
that want to flee war and come and seek
temporary refuge in the uk well i saw
your other tetchy exchange with james
cleverley and kay you were absolutely
right to put him under the cost frankly
if we have only issued 50 visas
amongst the thousands that want to come
to this country just think again british
government
we need to be generous we need to be
open-hearted for goodness sake we've got
an employment crisis in this country not
enough people to do to do jobs here so
um ukrainians are well-educated people
they're determined people
let's be generous open our doors and um
and let them come here we'll look after
them and they can work for us here too
refugees aren't people who just gonna
sit on street corners begging they'll
get out there do jobs they'll contribute
to our society so come on mr cleverley
and uh and the government um
extract the digit let's get this done
okay absolutely uh thank you my lord as
always much appreciated thanks kate
people from around the world have taken
up president silence's call for help in
the fight against russia let's speak to
one of them now bruce reed a retired
firefighter from north yorkshire who's
currently in poland on route to ukraine
um hiya thanks for joining us bruce your
family must think you're bonkers
can you hear me
oh i think we might have just lost him
that's such a shame can you hear me now
bruce
nope
we'll go back to bruce in just um a
second we're also going to be bringing
for you in just a few moments what
labour thinks about what the government
will be doing um as far as our economic
crime bill is concerned the government
want that in place for
in within six months uh labour is saying
that should be in place within 28 days
they're going to be discussing that in
the house of commons later on today and
we'll be discussing it with labor at the
top of the next hour uh before that
though um have a look at um should we
see if we can get bruce hi bruce
hello good morning ah there you are
sorry about that bruce but obviously you
are um in a very tricky situation uh
environment there at the moment i was
just started off by saying your family
must think you're absolutely bonkers
okay not just my family just what
everybody that i know thinks i am yeah
why are you doing this bruce
um
i mean like a lot of people you see here
what's what's going on and
you just i think everybody would
probably think
is there something that i can do
um
i went through the same thought process
and
obviously i know that recently aside
from the fire service
so perhaps that i could put that to some
views if it would make some good
uh so
i made some inquiries into the ukrainian
embassy
so uh to see if they would uh
need my services as a firefighter
retired firefighter uh that's the only
reason why i've come here
i've
i don't want to take up
have a crash course in the use of an
ak-47
but if i can
get to
the fire station in ukraine
and help them then then i might be doing
my bit
have you been given your orders yet do
you know what's expected of you
uh no we got
a bit of a
mix-up in getting here last night we got
here a little bit later than what we
expected and
i had to spend the night in a in a hotel
for you i'm still i'm still in the in
the now
uh i've uh i'm waiting for the
instructions hopefully by lunchtime or
early afternoon i'll know a bit clearer
as to what's expected of me
and how long are you planning to stay in
ukraine once you get there bruce
uh good question i i don't know i've
just said that i will play it by ear
and you know as long as i feel
that i'm doing some good and and i can
stay out there but
uh
at any point you know that i know that
uh
i've i need to get back to my family
because i've put them under
an awful lot of questions
you know i have i've got to think of
them as well so it's not just about me
you're a braver human than i am um bruce
and um well done you for doing this and
do keep in touch with us won't you um as
best you can and let us know what it's
like when you're there and if at any
stage you just want to come on the telly
and tell us what's going on uh we very
much appreciate you taking the time
okay thank you
thank you keep safe thank you just want
to bring you these pictures of a
youngster singing
um
i think in the last couple of days
[Music]
little girl kept ukrainian spirits up
even when holed up in a bomb shelter
with her rendition in ukrainian of let
it go look at her little face